pour débuter nous revenons sur ce ait
des débats d'hier entre les deux
finalistes à l'élection présidentielle
débat sous tension au ton
particulièrement agressif une brutalité
rarement vus et qui de l'avis des
analystes
elle devrait être plutôt défavorable à
marine le pen 16 millions et demi de
français étaient devant leur télé et
notamment les représentants
départementaux des mouvements en marche
et du front national
écouter à ses réactions moi je pense que
c'est un débat qui était nécessaire
candidats permis vraiment d'éclairer sur
les sur les postures des les candidats
des deux finalistes
on le voit dès ce matin sur avancions le
terrain est beaucoup de gens qui s'était
mis en retrait peut-être
abstentionnistes étaient sur un vote
blanc je pense qu'ils ont vraiment pris
conscience de ce que représente et
marine le pen et du danger qu'elles
représentent est avec ce programme et
qu'il s'était inventé en pet et même si
c'était peut-être pas le nom ainsi
emmanuel macron n'était pas le leur
candidat préféré est à voter pour
emmanuel macron et toi je pense que
beaucoup d'abstentionnistes ont changé
de côté et je précise que nous n'avons
pas réussi à contacter aujourd'hui à
joindre par téléphone le responsable
départemental du front national écoutez
néanmoins ces quelques réactions de
saint quentinois des propos recueillis
par stéphane servant et patrick jacques
de dixmude ce matin dans les rues de
saint quentin en yvelines
l'hyper agressif il n'y avait rien il ya
le par aucune consistance
voilà donc à partir de là dur dur pour
proférer un choix bah oui j'étais pas
vraiment macron là j'ai trouvé qu'il
était beaucoup plus clair sur ses idées
oui s'expliquer beaucoup mieux il avait
l'air très posé il avait aucun dossier
avec lui fin j'ai trouvé comment il
avait l'air vraiment sûr de lui un match
de boxe bat c'était vraiment
catastrophique et c'est vraiment à la
pâte projet du tout marine le pen et je
pense que les pas du tout à la hauteur
il s'interrompt paix sans cesse et le
journaliste maîtrisé par la situation
marine le pen à l'attaqué telle une
furie lui je crois qu'ils accueillent
garder son calme